kevin
is next kevin's in sacramento hi kevin
how are you
hey how's it going guys better than i
deserve what's up
so we've got a quick question um wife
and i are on the fence about staying in
california
we're thinking about moving to austin
texas area
um reason is because the housing market
where i'm at right now
is just uh it's pretty crazy over here
the houses over in that area would be
about half of what we would buy over
here
um where are you not unless you're in
silicon valley
well i'm in um roseville so a little bit
a little bit away but it's um
yeah it's not normal it's not i think
you're exactly
the houses are a lot cheaper in austin
texas but they're not half but okay
anyway your point is still
well for what i was looking for
basically
because i'm looking at it as if it would
be like more of a fresh start because we
paid off all of our debt
we have um uh three to six months fixed
uh saved up
and we're in the process of looking into
buying a home so
okay why would you stay in california
and why would you move
i'll stay in california and be at the
family but would move
because uh i feel like it'd be easier
to get a head start and kind of move
forward
with um with my wife and i where are you
moving what are you moving forward to
professionally
what's the dream
um with at least my role i feel like i'm
kind of
um i'm kind of topped out with what i'm
doing
i'm uh i'm in it
as a network engineer and if i want to
make more
then you know i can look into different
kind of fields
but i from like what i can do
progressing i feel like i've kind of fit
my feeling at least within
the field i'm in all right so have you
done homework you've done homework on
the housing have you done homework on
the type of companies the type of
positions the industries
uh that you would like to go into and do
they exist in austin
you know kind of what i'm gathering is
austin texas is like
silicon valley 2.0 nowhere
you gotta do some homework i mean this
is like uh it's it's like you're hearing
uh tabloid news you need to really do
some research before you make a move
like this now the good news is
good on you you guys have gotten debt
free
you're into baby step four you've got
the future in front of you but but
but don't go backwards financially
because you just decide well
this place over here seems like it's got
a lot of great opportunities we need to
have a plan
where am i going why do i want to go
there
how do i get there and that's that's
where you need to be on this i wouldn't
just
move uh for the sake of moving but i
mean there will be some financial
benefits to moving
obviously to texas versus california
austin has a tremendous tech scene
it's not silicon valley um
nashville's got a nashville nashville's
got a tremendous tech scene
but it's not silicon valley lots of town
lots of cities have
good strong presence of people in the
hardware world and people in the
software
world and there's several corridors
around that are stronger than
others and austin nashville will be
among them seattle would be among them
for sure but uh but but to call it 2.0
as if you're somehow it's nirvana or
something and the houses are
have priced half of what they are where
you are and the streets are paved with
gold too
no none of that's true so uh it's just
freaking austin texas so you need to go
do
a little more deep dive on your research
like ken said you've done a
really really good job with your money
kevin i'm very proud of you
and it sounds like you're kind of done
with california and so would the last
one out please turn off the lights
oh my gosh is everybody leaving that
state
it is unbelievable it feels like it i
mean it's
i'm talking to dallas realtors i'm
talking to nashville realtors i'm
talking to
wherever it's like 30 of their sales are
former californians
it's crazy people are coming to cities
like nashville and
austin and they're buying houses unseen
they're buying them off the internet
like they they go in of course they
could see what the house looks like boom
we're in
and here's what's happening not anything
to do with the house has got to do they
can go outside and they don't get
arrested
well and actually perform their business
yeah we're seeing small business men and
women
are suffering deeply on the west coast
because they cannot
go to work willing to move
from a good job and move away from his
family yeah
that that's you know and that's really
what's going on here so
yeah if the last one out just turns off
the lights let us know okay
so yeah um i i think you need to get on
a plane and go to austin do some
interviews and i think you need to look
at some actual houses with a real estate
agent
click elp at daveramsey.com one of our
endorsed local providers can
start to inform you in austin
uh how great a city it is it is a great
city i wasn't running it down
but it's not nirvana and um
you know it's not heaven uh and so
there's a great tech scene there
obviously but it is not the only
tech corridor in america where you could
possibly make a great living
there there's a lot of them and so you
need to start learning the market learn
the real estate market learn the job
market
and then based on all that knowledge
you'll make a much
better decision rather than just out of
your frustration
with the state of california this is the
dave ramsey show